this video is sponsored by the book
summary service
blinkist the first 100 people to use the
link in the description will receive one
week for free
and 25 off of full membership
modern humanity had waited its entire
life for this moment
one of the biggest questions almost
certainly pondered by just about every
person across nearly every culture
in every time and place of recent
history was now
finally answered our crew was the one to
make the discovery
in this moment we became the first
people of the first generation
to realize with certainty that we are
not alone
it was uncanny how similar they looked
to us besides their clothing
the only things that were
distinguishable were their widespread
noses
thin stretched lips and short somewhat
flattened skulls with long brows
they almost look like us if we just
rewound the clocks a million years or so
to our earliest ancient human ancestors
there were various other species on the
planet as well
quite a bit of plant life basic aquatic
life amoebas
bacteria and a variety of other
relatively small animals
all of which also look fairly similar to
earth-like species
following some scanning tests and
research we concluded that all were
relatively harmless
and only this one humanoid-like species
appeared to have a higher more complex
form of consciousness
[Music]
originally prior to the discovery our
group's mission was to scout and
establish new interplanetary bases
we were one of the first large crews to
travel out this far in this direction
we were primarily following up on probes
we sent out
to explore the resources and conditions
of potentially habitable planets
in order to begin the early developments
of possible further out
interplanetary societies upon the
discovery of life and this humanoid
looking species
on this particular lesser-known planet
though the goal of the mission
immediately became acquainting ourselves
and forming positive relations with them
they clearly possessed some form of
awareness and intelligence
operating within complex societies
speaking some sort of distinct languages
and appearing to function at a fairly
high level of intelligence
and so our objective was now to exchange
knowledge understanding
and resources as well as further
facilitate our initial endeavor
of developing a planetary base on this
clearly well-suited habitable planet
as part of my role in the group it
became my job to lead this endeavor
and ensure safe contact to maintain that
no diseases were transmitted from them
to us
or us to them and that there was no
unnecessary hostility or violence i was
also to serve at least initially
as the sole individual to communicate
and interact with the species
we believed that this would be less
threatening help maintain consistent
familiarity
and prevent it from appearing as though
we were ambushing them i contracted a
collection of the finest linguists
anthropologists sociologists
psychologists
and other scientists that we didn't
already have on board
positioned in our space station just
outside the planet's atmosphere
my team and i worked together via
hologram conferences
developing plans and strategies to make
the initial period of contact
as seamless and non-threatening as
possible
i then spent the following days
introducing myself to the species i was
monitored in close proximity
during all my interactions a full
defense security team ready at any
moment to step in
if anything went wrong surprisingly the
species didn't seem to take me as a
threat
at all they seemed almost immediately
happy to see me
like long-lost friends that reunited
after many years apart
initially i thought this could be a
strange subversion tactic
it was so surreal but i soon found
myself realizing it was simply the
genuine purity and warmth of the species
they were so happy and almost utopian
like perfect happiness
there was a bliss and love and
connection in them that was unlike
anything i had ever seen before
they welcomed me right in over the
following weeks
i spent more and more time with and
amongst them jumping back and forth
between their society and the space
station
i researched and took notes capturing
audio recordings and footage of most of
my interactions
at the end of each day the team and i
spent time assessing everything
evaluating the state of their
civilization the condition of their
consciousness
the development of their technology and
so forth
in summary they appeared to have strange
minimal technology
by our standards they seemed to almost
have none or perhaps just kinds that
were hard for us to see
and understand ultimately in general
the way they lived made very little
sense to us in spite of this apparent
lacking of technology and scientific
practices
they appeared to be very high
functioning both intellectually
societally and politically we felt and
saw it but couldn't really understand it
they were human-like clearly possessing
some similar form of consciousness and
intelligence
but they seem to live in an almost
perfect harmony with each other
and the planet like one massive symphony
endlessly playing a tune of bliss
and any missed notes or problems were
glossed over and barely noticed they
lived with an
unequivocal serenity within this
functioning on a smooth confident
intuition
as if they had a perfect understanding
of everything
they also all seem to constantly possess
a childlike innocence and joy
regardless of their age or anything else
i can't even really properly translate
it
rationally intellectually it was almost
incomprehensible
we had so many questions for them of
course
in order to ask anything we needed to be
able to talk with each other
and so over the course of the following
weeks i worked with my team to decipher
and translate their language to the best
of our abilities
the species didn't talk a lot at least
compared to us
but their language was still relatively
clear and consistent
and we deemed it to be translatable
eventually after sufficiently learning
their language i became the first person
to ever successfully talk with a living
thing that wasn't a person
i started simple demonstrating my
ability to tentatively understand their
language system
terminology and vocal tones the language
was strange
it lacked a large essential portion of
what existed in all modern human
languages
words that would translate even loosely
into subordinate conjunctions like
whether
if and since but most significantly
their language lacked all question
phrases we discovered this when i began
trying to ask them
questions but couldn't find the words
phrasings or tones in their language to
allow me to do so
and furthermore when i gestured at an
item or a task or a ritual
in a manner that i hoped might imply an
unawareness or confusion
they only stated or repeated the term or
sound or action used to represent it
as if there was nothing more to know
they seem to entirely lack the sense or
capacity
or interest in questioning things
now with the solid basis of
communication my team and i redirected
our efforts towards teaching the species
the english language by now several
additional team members
mostly linguists and language teachers
have begun periodically joining me on
excursions and meetings with a species a
part of the protocol of the mission
required
in such a scenario that we either obtain
permission
or sufficiently demonstrate a lack of
consciousness in the planet's species
in order to move forward with building a
base on their planet
they were clearly not unconscious so
that was out
but in order to ask them questions and
get their permission
we first had to teach them what
questions were
slowly but surely we taught them we
taught them what i meant when i asked
who they were what they liked
what they wanted why they did this or
that and so on
it was an incredibly slow and surreal
process like teaching fundamental
infant level concepts to a fully
intelligent well-functioning adult but
even after some of the species began to
successfully learn the english language
and understand the concept of a question
for a long time
they still didn't seem to understand
what an answer might be or perhaps more
accurately
why an answer might be that part simply
didn't make sense to them
things just were there was no relevant
knowledge to be had underneath things
or beyond things everything was and what
was to be known
was already known through experience
through intuition
in an effort to help this process along
and further showcase who we were
and what we could offer them i brought
various forms of our technologies onto
the planet
examples of our sciences our
philosophies our logic and our knowledge
i showed them
i taught them eventually after a long
difficult effort their understanding of
questioning and answering
began to form they first started by
answering questions with questions
why do we need questions was i believe
the first question one of them asked
it was then that i knew we had finally
bridged the last large gap
now that they began to better understand
again i began asking them things like
what this item was
and what that item did i asked them why
they got up in the middle of the night
and sang songs
i asked them what they called themselves
and what they called their planet
i asked them more abstract things as
well like how they were so happy all the
time
and what they thought happiness was i
asked them how they loved so
openly and unconditionally and what they
thought love was
i asked them about their culture and
politics and how it worked
why it worked i asked them what they
thought the meaning of life was
what they considered their purpose how
they viewed and explained aspects of
nature
and the universe i asked them about
their sciences and technologies and
philosophies and religions
or more accurately what appeared to be
the lack thereof
they still didn't really understand
these sorts of questions they
essentially explained to me that
happiness was happiness love was love
life was life
and when i prodded further they had
nothing more
they seem to not possess any real
knowledge or understanding of things
they seem to not know nor care of the
truth
as more time passed though and as we
began to build an entire base on the
planet
now with their permission they slowly
started wondering what these things were
the questions i asked them seemed to
grow inside their head spreading out
across their entire being
individually and collectively they began
to wonder what made them happy
and how they could be happier they
questioned why they loved
who they loved and what love was made of
they evaluated how their social systems
worked
if they even really did and how they
could improve them
they pondered why they existed and what
the point was
they didn't have the answers anymore now
they had the questions
soon i observed what i can only describe
as the fall of their nearly utopian
heavenly civilization they started
denying and arguing over what was what
they began making things up and lying to
each other some appeared to become
hostile
corrupt and deceptive eventually they
began
asking what we were doing there what we
wanted who we were
they questioned if we were good for them
they doubted us
they doubted me they doubted themselves
fairly quickly we had to abandon the
mission and retreat
back to the space station we went never
to return
we have monitored the planet ever since
the species has continued to rapidly
develop
technologically and intellectually
building off what we left them
they engage in regular wars now as well
as other forms of conflicts and
disruptions
the planet is no longer inhabitable by
us unless we wish to fight with the
species
unless we are willing to destroy them in
the end
we failed the mission they did not
attack us we did not attack them
we did not pass along any diseases but
we infected them
nonetheless it has been many years and
many planets since that encounter
we have not met anyone else since nor
returned
but i personally always return to the
memory of that planet
of that species specifically i always
find myself pondering with great
intensity
an idea that i have not been able to
shake ever since that mission
one essential question that i found at
the bottom of everything
of all questions did that species know
the truth of things more
or less before we arrived and thought we
taught it to them
have they gotten closer to truth through
their newly developed capacity
and implementation of questioning and
reasoning science and technology
or were they closer to the truth before
is the knowledge of nature
of love of happiness of life closer
or further to the truth of any of these
things
the species had not questioned what
happiness was and yet they were
blissfully happy
they had not questioned what love was
and they loved boundlessly
they had not questioned the point of
life and they lived with great purpose
they did not understand how nature
worked and yet they lived naturally
and fluidly now they possess the
knowledge
the reason and the technology to dissect
and understand
all of these things to so-called improve
all of these things
and yet now they struggle with them
that species was living life now they
like us
work to deconstruct and understand it to
define it
they work to take all the pieces of the
working system apart
in order to see how it all goes together
but now they
like us are left with the mess of all
the parts
and the unbelievable challenge of
successfully putting them back together
again
this video was sponsored by blinkist
as information becomes more abundant and
accessible with so much to choose from
the psychological weight we put on
investing large amounts of time
into full books can feel increasingly
heavy and hard to manage
the book summary service blinkist helps
counteract and reduce this weight by
making it much easier to both engage in
larger numbers of books
in smaller amounts of time as well as
help you more effectively sift through
and discover high quality authors topics
and complete books that you're
potentially interested in reading
prior to having to read the full
versions first by condensing thousands
of non-fiction books into around
15-minute summaries
blinkist helps you do all of this by
providing the most important ideas and
key takeaways
of complete books in a convenient amount
of time
if you're interested in topics related
to evolution and the milestones of
conscious and technological development
within human history blinkist has some
great titles
including cosmo sapiens by john hans
the upright thinkers by leonard melodna
as well as many others
and now for topics books and authors
that you find you are more interested in
you can explore further by using
blinkist's podcast summary shortcasts
or purchasing the complete audiobook
versions of certain book titles
directly within the app as well the
first 100 people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access
as well as 25 off a premium membership
the free 7-day trial
can be canceled at any time within the
trial period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you